[Musica]
le aziende responsabili e sostenibili
sono aziende che fanno più soldi degli
altri
purtroppo l'idea è che non sia così
purtroppo pensiamo che i furbi sono
quelli che fanno più soldi degli altri
però nei prossimi pochi minuti io vi
voglio convincere che le aziende
responsabili e sostenibili sono le
aziende più competitive di tutti però
iniziò con una storia personale il viso
con una storia personale io ho passato i
primi 15 agli ultimi 15 anni lavorando
tutta la mia vita era basata sul lavoro
ho partorito con il telefonino in mano
rispondendo agli e mail all attacco in
consiglio di amministrazione
ho perso i primi due compleanni di mio
figlio che ha due anni e mezzo per cui
due su due
ero in viaggio e non ho potuto stare con
lui è un giorno ha deciso che questo era
troppo non andava bene la mia vita non
era quello che io volevo per cui sono
andata dal mio direttore generale e gli
ho detto non è una posizione part time
lui mi ha guardato e mi ha detto part
time c'è la fila di gente gli uomini che
sta aspettando di coprire la tua
posizione
se non sei disponibile a lavorare 24 ore
al giorno quelle alla porta per prima
volta in tutta la mia vita ho toccato
con mano cosa voleva dire a lavorare in
un'azienda irresponsabile e
insostenibile quindi da allora cerco di
convincere le persone a che a capire che
le aziende responsabili e sostenibili
sono le aziende che realmente riescono
ad essere più competitive viviamo in un
mondo dove riceviamo tantissimi messaggi
per cui è importante capire che cos'è la
sostenibilità e cos'è la responsabilità
prima di tutto la responsabilità e la
responsabilità nei confronti delle
persone
le persone che lavorano nelle aziende i
clienti i nostri fornitori
poi dobbiamo essere sostenibili
economicamente l'azienda che non è
sostenibile economicamente è l'azienda
più responsabile perché chiude licenzia
tutti e poi dobbiamo essere sostenibili
nei confronti dell'ambiente e del
pianeta in cui viviamo le aziende
sostenibili sono anche le aziende che
rispettano l'ambiente
e dove viviamo viviamo in un mondo pieno
di messaggi siamo bombardati dalla
pubblicità
abbiamo dei clienti assolutamente
infedeli i ragazzi giovani cambiano
marca continuamente prima compravamo lo
stesso detersivo tutta la vita e adesso
cambiamo perché se c'è un'offerta
compriamo un detersivo differente il
mondo dove viviamo delle risorse
estremamente limitate così limitate che
fra qualche anno finirà oris portiamo a
questo mondo o non riusciremo veramente
a vivere in futuro è difficile vendere
anche perché l'uno per cento della
popolazione possiede il 50 per cento
della ricchezza che c'è nel mondo o
vendiamo a quell'uno per cento o
vendiamo al resto 99 però è difficile
siamo collegati ad internet tutto il
tempo e quando siamo collegati ad
internet parliamo di marche e quando
parliamo delle marche in facebook o in
twitter normalmente parliamo male di
loro
le aziende hanno fatto tante cose
sbagliate hanno dato messaggi scorretti
con la pubblicità è oggigiorno siamo
scettici il marketing ci sembra qualcosa
come di negativo la gente vuole che le
aziende siano trasparenti e questo è
difficile per la maggior parte di loro
in più dobbiamo renderci conto che le
persone si chiedono a chiedono alle
aziende che le aziende siano una forza
per fare il bene non semplicemente che
vendono dei prodotti questo non è
sufficiente
in più vendere in questo mondo è
difficile quasi tutti i prodotti alla
fine sono uguali quasi tutti i
telefonini funzionano quasi tutti i
prodotti che compriamo al supermercato
sono più o meno buoni
vendere in questo mondo è difficile
siamo immersi in moltitudine di marche
dobbiamo differenziarci ma questa
differenza non è sufficiente di per sé
essere differenti nel mercato non è
sufficiente se il cliente non apprezza
questa differenza è il cliente non è
disposto a pagare il prezzo di questa
differenza siamo solo differenti ma non
vendiamo di più
sappiamo però che il 40 per cento dei
clienti vorrebbe che le marche
rappresentassero qualcosa in più che
semplicemente il beneficio utile del
prodotto il telefonino che funzioni un
detersivo che lava eccetera
sappiamo che il 40 per cento delle
persone che stanno lì fuori
vogliono delle marche che rappresentano
dei valori tra la maggior parte delle
aziende non sono in grado di
rappresentare questi valori però ci sono
alcune aziende che grazie alla
sostenibilità e grazie alla
responsabilità sociale riescono ad
essere differenti e riescono ad essere
più competitive nel mercato vediamo
degli esempi vodafone non vendeva nessun
prodotto in africa e in india perché in
questi paesi la gente non parla al
telefonino
però c'è un'opportunità di mercato
l'opportunità di mercato era che la
gente non ha accesso alle banche per cui
avere denaro liquido in africa o in
india è molto difficile
in più quando la gente va alla banca e
cerca di fare per esempio un bonifico la
persona che allo sportello si tiene una
commissione è normalmente questa
commissione non è così legale per cui
vodafone vede un opportunità nel mercato
decide di trasformarsi in una banca
online grazie al telefonino
le persone possono pagare nei negozi
possono fare piccoli bonifici possono
anche chiedere di microcrediti grazie a
questo lavoro è questa opportunità che
ha accolto vodafone un ultimo studio di
mckinsey ha detto che nei prossimi dieci
anni
il prodotto interno lordo di questi due
paesi
aumenterà del 6 per cento un altro
esempio wall mart pullman è uno dei
supermercati più importanti degli stati
uniti è probabilmente una delle marche
più odiate del mondo perché diciamo la
verità sono sempre stati abbastanza
insostenibile a livello ecologico e
hanno sempre trattato un po male i loro
dipendenti
quindi reputazione ormai era per niente
un livello zero nel 2009 decidono che
devono cambiare strategia e iniziano il
cambio
grazie a una politica ecologica
differente
la prima cosa che fanno è di decidere di
cambiare il packaging è la maggior parte
dei loro prodotti e li sono coni complex
se avete mai aperto una scatola di
complex quando tirate fuori il sacchetto
la scatola grande così il prodotto è
così c'è mezzo pacchetto è pieno d'aria
ora quando ha deciso di fare non sono
andate alle varie fornitori di conflicts
che hanno detto vogliamo i pacchetti di
conflicts grandi come la quantità del
prodotto e perché perché l'ho fatto
questo ragionamento pacchetti più
piccoli vuol dire più pacchetti in ogni
camion che vuol dire meno camion in
circolazione che vuol dire meno benzina
e ovviamente meno ossido di carbonio
grazie a questa perfetto sillogismo in
tre anni hanno risparmiato 3.000 milioni
di dollari sull'in benzina e ovviamente
hanno rispettato l'ecologia in modo
importante hanno migliorato la loro
reputazione
un altro esempio patagonia patagonia una
delle aziende più importanti che
producono vestiti per andare in montagna
questo è il loro messaggio di marketing
non comprate questa giacca
uno dice come non comprate questa già
con l'azienda che vuoi vendere dice di
non comprare e di un'azienda che
promette ai propri azionisti
l'aumento del 10 per cento ogni anno
delle loro vendite
qua c'è qualcosa che non quadra se io
chiedo alla gente di non comprare i miei
prodotti come posso vendere il 10 per
cento in più dei miei prodotti ogni anno
perché i loro clienti sono fedelissimi i
loro clienti considerano chi chi ama
veramente la montagna compra patagonia
perché patagonia la marca più rispettosa
ecologicamente nel loro sistema di
produzione e anche se chiedono la gente
di non comprare i propri prodotti di
riusarli di rammentargli di regalarli
purché ci sia questa cycle economy pur
che la gente continui a utilizzare i
propri prodotti
loro fanno soldi perché sono i più cari
di tutti ma se lo possono permettere
perché i loro clienti sono i più fedeli
del mercato
poi c'è ci sono dei supermercati in
inghilterra che stanno facendo una
campagna contro l'obesità come lo fanno
sotto a il ticket sotto allo scontrino
vetro dei bollini se ci sono tanti
bollini rossi vuol dire che la spesa che
la persona ha fatto nel suo carrello e
pieno di grassi carboidrati e troppe
calorie quindi quando una persona guarda
lo scontrino dice fu ho fatto una spesa
ben poco sana stanno cercando di
sensibilizzare l'opinione pubblica
soprattutto in questi paesi dove
l'obesità è un gran problema soprattutto
l'obesità infantile stanno cercando di
sensibilizzare le persone a comprare
cose più sane di frutta più verdura cosi
integrali e stanno cercando di farlo poi
ci sono le aziende che dicono siti come
il mio costume da bagno ti trasformi
cindy crawford naomi campbell
ci sono aziende che lo permettono e poi
ci sono aziende che dicendo di dare un
messaggio differente come dadi e dicono
io ti vendo una crema questa crema che
renderà il più bello possibile però con
i tuoi pregi e con i tuoi difetti e poi
alla fine ci sono aziende come
volkswagen
tutti sappiamo che un anno fa il
settembre dell'anno scorso
volkswagen è stata la protagonista di un
grande scandalo uno scandalo perché
avevano truccato il software che
misurava l'anidride carbonica che usciva
dalle macchine diesel è stato lo
scandalo così grande che a parte aver
quasi distrutto la deputazione di questa
azienda
un mese dopo la luce quando lo scandalo
aveva già era già arrivato ai sui
giornali e sulle televisioni
un mese dopo volkswagen aveva perso il
42 per cento del valore del prezzo per
ogni azione in borsa non recupereranno
mai la perdita di denaro che hanno avuto
a causa della propria insostenibilità
però non è solo per colpa delle
multinazionali signori questo è un
castello di catalunya famoso ci sono
sono notti rabin e umana ci sono tutte
queste persone vanno un insieme
all'altra fanno una pira bile umana
arrivano essere nove piani e la persona
che in cima e un bambino piccolo che
normalmente a 45 anni
ogni persona che sta facendo questo
castello ha una responsabilità
incredibile se sono uno di loro non
mantiene perfettamente in tensione tutti
i suoi muscoli la torre umana cave e
questa è la stessa cosa per la
sostenibilità
ognuno di noi ognuno di noi ha il
responsabile di essere sostenibile nei
confronti dell'energia nei confronti
della natura nei confronti delle persone
con cui lavoriamo nei confronti delle
persone che sono i nostri clienti e
ovviamente nei confronti dei benefici
aziendali per cui vi faccio l'ultima
domanda sapendo che tutti siamo
responsabili nei confronti della
sostenibilità aziendale
produciamo vediamo e compriamo prodotti
che rispettano il futuro dei nostri
figli
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]